[Music]
these men and women make a part of the
largest haitian expat community in latin
america
after their country's 2010 earthquake
chile opened its doors to tens of
thousands of haitians
but today even as thousands of
undocumented venezuelans colombians and
peruvians are flocking to chile
huge numbers of haitians are actually
leaving on the u.s mexico border
hundreds of haitians have discarded
their chilean id cards
as they risk their lives trying to reach
u.s shores
the question is why would they leave
chile the country with the highest per
capita income in the region
the treatment that haitians receive here
from chile's current president is
indecent that's why they decide to
journey to el dorado even if they die on
the way because they are sure they will
be treated better
the death of a young haitian mother
shook the community to the core
two years ago twenty-seven-year-old
joanne florville who did not speak
spanish was arrested and later taken
from the police station to the hospital
in a coma
her sister says that floorbill had been
accused of abandoning her two-month-old
baby at a municipal office when in fact
she had only left her in her stroller
with a guard for a few minutes while she
tried to find someone to translate for
her
samantha agreed to speak to us for the
first time about what her sister told
her before she died a month later
including charges that she was badly
beaten by police
orlando that's why she cried so much she
told me the police and others treat
haitians badly here she said they treat
haitians like dogs but actually that's
not true because here they treat dogs
quite well
samantha nevertheless wants to remain in
chile to be near her deceased sister's
child who lives with her father
she adds that not all chileans are bad
such as roxanna her brother's girlfriend
but racism and discrimination of
haitians are widespread
in chile many associate haitians with
compassion they are seen as people who
are socially degraded defenseless
inferior in some ways but racism isn't
exclusively about the color of one's
skin discrimination is based on class
it's poverty that makes the difference
at a migrant assistance center in
santiago we meet another haitian migrant
who asked not to be identified for fear
of reprisals
she says the main problem isn't racism
it's the government's refusal to issue
or renew working documents for most
haitians
if you want to work you have to have an
id card and to have an id card you need
to work so if you can't get papers how
can you work you can't live decently
that's why the majority of my friends
have left the country i have no friends
left
approximately 90 percent of haitians in
chile don't have valid residency papers
which makes them open to rampant abuse
from landlords and unscrupulous
employers and ineligible for social
services
chile's current government has become
more hostile towards undocumented
migrants especially those who for
example are working in the informal
sector critics say that it has done
little or nothing to promote social
inclusion nor to crack down on illegal
exploitation of patients all of which is
keeping them at the bottom of the social
and economic ladder in this country
and until that changes the majority of
haitians who came here thinking they had
reached the promised land will continue
to live in squalor and suffer
discrimination
lucia newman al jazeera santiago